[Musique]
à les entendre maintenant retentir
l'hymne national la marseillaise
[Musique]
comment
non
oh
[Musique]
je vais des macros thibault l'arrivée
d'emmanuel macron qui elle-même est
également très applaudi exactement
vincent vous le voyez le couple macron
qui donc bien monte les marches
désormais de cette église saint sulpice
sous les applaudissements en effet de la
foule rassemblée au jo
[Musique]
oh
le
[Musique]
il y avait chez notre ancien président
cet homme chaleureux soutenu par son
épouse bernadette un véritable amour des
gens aussi à l'aise dans les salons de
l'elysée qu'au salon de l'agriculture
beaucoup en le rencontrant se sentaient
considérés son amour pour sa famille
était profond et bien que pudiques
chacun a pu percevoir l'attendre
compassion qu'il avait pour la
vulnérabilité de sa fille laurence
[Musique]
oh
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est quoi
moi
le
venus en nombre et là on voit claude
chirac et son fils qui remercie les
parisiens et les provinciaux qui sont
venus pour assister à la cérémonie
ce qui était intéressant quand vous
disiez tout à l'heure la famille chirac
qui sortaient de l'église est juste
derrière il y avait françois et françois
pinault et son épouse qu'on ne peut pas
dissocier de la famille chirac c'est
vraiment voilà on sait que que jacques
chirac était